I think when people are choosing between
like growth or monetization like they
think that that decision applies to
every single kind of company and I think
like for some companies that make sense
that you're going to pursue growth and I
think the way you're thinking about
growth is in terms of like people who
decide to hold off I'm on a decision
until later and usually that means that
you have to build some other kind of
asset that allows you to sell so for
example social networks are the easiest
one right the thing you ultimately the
way you're going to monetize that is
like your audience or your user base and
that information that you have from
there and the only way you're going to
get that is if you have a large amount
of information and so you focus on
growth in regards to like getting people
and getting people engaged and
what-have-you and then the monitor will
happen because like you finally have
product market fit where like
advertisers say like this is enough
information or data this is enough
audience that we're willing to pay for
this most b2b companies or enterprise
companies you don't think like that it's
it's actually far more straightforward
it's a one-to-one relationship I'm
making something I'm making a service
and on whatever parameters that you
think you're paid a great trigger is
whether it's convenience or it helps you
make more money or like it saves you on
time or energy or people or cost savings
right that one-to-one relation is a lot
more straightforward and you can say
like oh the obviously it makes that I
it's test for that